and Abdi Fatah Hersey is a 25 year old
journalist for radio show Bela in
Mogadishu
he works hard as a local reporter
Somalia has been embroiled in conflict
and civil war for more than 25 years but
listeners still want to hear ordinary
news - Abdi gives a weather report for
the Somali capital journalists have
often paid with their lives for
reporting on the violence in their
country rival clans waging war
skyrocketing corruption or the plight of
Somalis in exile this is a report about
violent Somali demonstrations in Nairobi
Abdi has escaped death by living and
working in secret many other reporters
have not been as lucky the director of
radio show Bella shows us how many of
his reporters have been killed dr. Logan
gadelle apart job is dangerous six of
our colleagues have been killed I buried
them with my own hands thank you I'm
gonna have to get a key back to him but
then I'm Caracalla he wouldn't talk the
Committee to Protect Journalists says
that over the last two decades 62
reporters died doing their work in
Somalia go away Somalia is among the
nations with the highest number of
journalists being killed in the world
the current government tries to improve
the situation but tangible results are
yet to come
meaning that in the coming period a lot
of Somali journalists will continue to
be killed or just other Abdi Fatah her
she is aware of this danger but he wants
to keep reporting the news to his
community an hire had the awkward way I
know that being a reporter here in
Mogadishu is dangerous I know that by
doing this job I could end up dead but I
don't want to stop I plan to continue oh
I am with Georgia where Monica hung over
a sauna in ASEAN
the threat posed by al-shabaab militia
shows no sign of letting up
so Somali reporters like Abdul Fattah
Hersey will continue to work in
extremely hazardous conditions